-You know, our next guest
from "Saturday Night Live."
She also produces, writes,
and stars in the show "Shrill."
All episodes of
the third and final season
will be on Hulu this Friday.
Everyone, please welcome
Aidy Bryant!
-♪ It's Aidy Bryant ♪
♪ And she's dressed to kill ♪
♪ She's mighty, mighty ♪
♪ On that show called "Shrill" ♪
♪ It's Aidy Bryant ♪
♪ It's her turn to drive ♪
♪ Up to the eighth floor ♪
♪ On "Saturday Night Live" ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-That's gotta feel good, right?
-Ohh. So nice!
Wow! It's really nice
to have a crowd.
-It's amazing, right?
-Yeah.
-As a performer,
this -- it's everything.
-You need 'em.
-It's everything.
-We need ya.
-Yeah, we totally do.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
I know you're busy. You got
a new show this Saturday.
I gotta say
you're crushing it this season.
-Oh, thanks!
-And I will say
that my favorite thing so far
that you're doing now --
This new character you're doing.
Ted Cruz.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughter ]
-This is when he came back
from Cancun. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-Did you know you had
a Ted Cruz in you?
And what --
-I -- I still am amazed
that I'm finding him every day
in there.
Um, no. I didn't know.
And, also, I didn't --
You know, normally,
like, sometimes during the week,
you have an idea
that an impression is coming up.
And him in particular,
it kind of, like,
sprung up on us on Friday.
And so, Saturday morning
I went in, and they were like,
"You have Ted Cruz. Okay."
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Isn't that wild?
-I just was like, "Okay.
I'll put something
together, but..."
And then I felt like, okay,
well, that'll be my only time
I did Ted Cruz.
And then it was, like,
week after week.
They were like,
"Get the beard out!"
-"Get the beard back out!
People want to hear the hits!
They want the Ted Cruz."
Yeah, exactly.
Because you're doing that,
as well as "Shrill,"
which, by the way,
congratulations.
It comes out on Friday.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All the episodes on Friday,
but Friday is also
your birthday, by the way.
-I know!
-Happy birthday!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Happy, happy birthday!
-You know, yeah, it's a lot.
It's a lot of attention
for me on one day, I think.
I'm scared that I'll never
be the same afterwards.
-Yeah, I mean,
you couldn't plan this
if you planned it
four years in advance.
-No, I -- It was not my idea.
I want people to know that.
That was --
They just chose the date.
And I was like,
"That's my birthday."
And they were like,
"Okay. We don't care." Um...
-This season, I know you --
There was an episode
where you had to learn
the Electric Slide.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-And you were talking to me
about this.
Now, why did it bother you?
Or not bother you.
But why is it still
in your brain that you --
-No, I think it was -- It became
a big moment for me in my life.
-All right. Explain this.
-Well, you know,
you think you know
the Electric Slide, don't ya?
-Of course. Yeah.
We all know it.
-You've all been to a wedding
or a bat mitzvah.
You know --
You know the Electric Slide.
-Yes.
-Well, so, we wrote it
into the show.
It was like, okay,
this girls' night out.
The four girls are going to do
the Electric Slide.
And the director,
Carrie Brownstein, was like,
"I think we should get
a choreographer
just so you guys look
really tight and all together."
And in my mind, I was like,
"Okay, lady.
We don't need a choreographer.
We know it."
-Yeah, it's the Electric Slide.
-And so they got
the choreographer.
And it just so happened that,
like, when we were
supposed to rehearse,
I had an issue with my costume,
so the other girls
went and rehearsed.
And then right when I could
join them, they were done.
And then it was just me
and a professional choreographer
in a huge room.
And it was like,
"Do the Electric Slide."
-That's pressure.
-And it was
the most intimate, raw,
nightmarish pain I've ever felt
in my entire life.
And suddenly I found myself
being like,
"What is the Grapevine?
What is a little shimmy?"
Like, I'm -- Raw terror
looking into this man's eye.
-"I've done this
a million times.
Is this the Electric Slide?"
-So then I think
because of that,
he was like, "This woman doesn't
know the Electric Slide.
She needs extra help."
I would say, for 20 minutes,
I quietly did the Electric Slide
for a professional choreographer
probably 10 times in a row.
Solo Electric Slide?
It will chill you
to your damn bones.
-All right. Yeah. We get that.
-But I survived.
-You survived. You did it.
-It looked great on camera.
Oh, wow.
-You film the show
in and around Portland.
-Yeah.
-Gosh. That's --
-It's the best.
-That's a cool place.
-And it's, like, such
a cool town to explore.
And we went, like,
all these areas around it.
We went to the beach.
We went to this cattle ranch
we shot on.
-Oh, yeah.
-And -- Yeah.
There's, like, a scene
where we shot at this
full-working cattle ranch,
and we thought it would be funny
to write in that a child
on an ATV comes
and picks me up and takes me
across the cattle ranch.
But I didn't realize that meant,
like, actually a child
would drive me on an ATV
across a cattle ranch.
-We actually have a clip of
the scene you're talking about.
Here's Aidy Bryant in the
new season of "Shrill" on Hulu.
Take a look.
-Hi!
[ Engine idling ]
Uh, I'm here
to meet Clara Pickett.
[ Engine idling ]
Okay.
Sorry.
I've never been one of these.
So I'm gonna grab on there.
Okay.
[Straining]
Just give it one of these.
Okay. Okay.
Um, is it okay if I put my hands
on your back here?
Little support from a child.
Okay.
Ohh. [ Chuckles ]
All right.
So I'm good
to leave my car there?
Okay.
-Come on. Show business, man.
Happy early birthday.
Aidy Bryant, everybody.
All episodes of the third
and final season of "Shrill"
will be on Hulu this Friday.